la raison principale c'était pour
instaurer la paix on apprend plus sur
l'Union européenne et voyager tout en
restant à Paris c'est possible tout au
long du parcours on les visiteurs
découvrent des installations en réalité
augmentée et même un cinéma à 360 degrés
donc c'est un film de 8 minutes environ
qui est quand on passe en boucle ici en
bas et c'est un film qui parle un peu de
l'histoire de l'Europe pourquoi nous
Européens on s'est mis ensemble dans
cette union quelles sont les raisons et
donc il y a peu d'historique mais après
il y a aussi surtout aussi une partie
sur sur les défis futurs aussi pourquoi
on doit rester ensemble autre expérience
interactive cette carte au sol à l'aide
d'une tablette les visiteurs peuvent
réviser leur géographie et s'informer
sur divers projets européens partout sur
le continent donc aujourd'hui on est
avec des jeunes du programme Movin
organisé par la Maison de l'Europe c'est
des jeunes en insertion professionnelle
qui vont faire un stage
Erasmus a Dublin ou Malaga l'idée c'est
que
ils partent en ayant connaissance de qui
finance ce projet et donc l'Union
européenne les institutions et les
différents États membres comment
s'organise l'Union européenne et à quoi
elle sert avant de partir en mobilité en
Irlande et en Espagne ces jeunes
originaire des Yvelines ont pu en
apprendre plus sur les institutions et
sur les euros députés français
l'Union européenne a joué sur beaucoup
d'aspects que ce soit dans la société en
France mais dans tous les autres pays et
que ça c'était très important
on se rend pas compte forcément de
tout le spectre qui englobe l'Union
européenne outre Paris Strasbourg
Bruxelles Tallinn et Berlin ont déjà
leur repas expérience objectif pour lieu
ouvrir un espace de ce type dans chaque
capitale européenne avant les prochaines
élections prévues en 2024